في اخبارنا الاخرى قال وزير الداخليه
التركي علي يرلي كايا ان القوات الامنيه
قتلت مسلحين اثنين حاول مهاجمه قصر عدل
جاج لايان في اسطنبول واضاف الوزير ان
خمسه اشخاص اصيبوا في اطلاق النار بينهم
شرطيان واضاف وزير الداخليه في منشور على
موقع اكس ان الهجوم الذي وصفه بالارهابي
نفذته جبهه حزب التحرير الشعبي
الثوري معنا من حيط قصر العدل في اسطنبول
حيث وقع الحادث مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج
ما المعلومات
عمر نعم مياده من خلفي هنا والمكان الذي
شهد قبل نحو ساعه من الان هذا الهجوم الذي
وصفته السلطات بال الارهابيه على قصر
العدل وصل وسط مدينه اسطنبول قصر عدل
تشيان هذا المكان كما تشاهدون خلفي في
الصوره هناك هذه الباصات باصات الشرطه
هناك جسدا يقع جسدي هذين المنفذين ل
الهجوم تفاصيل الهجوم التي ذكرتها الوسائل
الرسميه وان هذين الشخصين احدهما امراه
حاولا الدخول الى داخل قصر العدل عندما
اشتبه اشتبهت بهم قوات الامن المسؤوله عن
حمايه هذا المكان اشتبكا معهما قوات
الشرطه استطاعت ان تردي كلا المهاجمين
قتيلين ولكن المهاجمين ايضا تسببا باصابه
خمسه اشخاص منهم ثلاثه من رجال الشرطه قبل
قليل وصلت سياره اسعاف خاصه من جهاز العدل
التركي من وزاره ال الداخليه اضافه الى
نائب عام عينه مباشره وزير العدل ير ليكاي
للتحقيق في هذه الحادثه كما ذكرتم في
الخبر فان وزير العدل مباشره قال ان هذا
الهجوم هو هجوم ارهابي نفذته جماعه ايه
التحرير هي جماعه يساريه نشات منذ عام
1978 واتبعت اسلوب العنف منذ عام
1994 للمفارق هذا الهجوم ياتي بعد تسع
سنوات من اخر هجوم نفذته هذه الجماعه على
هذه على قصر العدل هذا على تشاغليان حيث
قتل احد النواب العامين الاتراك في ذلك
الهجوم هذه الجماعه مصنفه ارهابيه في
تركيا منذ عام 94 كما ذكرت هي جماعه ذات
خلفيه ماركسيه لينين كما تصفها وزاره
الداخليه كانت تستخدم اساليب من قبيل
الاغتيال وايضا الهجوم الهجمات الانتحاريه
وكذلك الهجمات المسلحه على مخافر الشرطه
وتستهدف بعض النواب العامين الذين يحكمون
في قضايا او باحكام مشدده ضد منسوبي هذه
الجماعه حتى الان لا نعرف بالضبط ما هو
الهدف من الهجوم هل هي شخصيه من القضاه او
احد الواب العامين ام انها كانت فقط
الهجوم على المكان ذاته كما ذكرت الشرطه
ايضا كانت خلال الساعه الماضيه قد ارسلت
مجموعه من الحوامات للبحث عن مشتبهين
اخرين قد يكونوا تعاونوا مع هؤلاء عمر
الحاج من محيط قصر العدل في اسطنبول شكرا
جزيلا لك